1700 video fatto difficile vana intro
che non sia uguale a tutte le altre però
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa ejei oggi
siamo tornati su 100 floors a great
flores lo facciamo mezzo italiano e
mezzo inglese perché fa figo la facciamo
continua risposto un attimino sono mi
vedete coperto dal dal telefono questo
gioco per chi non lo conoscesse consiste
nello scalare questa torre gigante fatta
di 100 piani
ero arrivato al piano numero 30 c
sicuramente un codice che devo capire
che però non so quale punteria qua
dentro ci sorprese degli indizi che ti
spiegano che ora devi mettere però non
so bene qual è il cav h invece qualcosa
che non sto vedendo c'è qualcosa che mi
segnala posizione delle lancette sono le
8 e 07 veramente dovevo mettere l'orario
del telefono ma geniale sta cosa
tieni genio assoluto nella vita numero
era il primo livello di oggi gli altri
livelli quelli dello scorso episodio li
ho fatti in un nanosecondo questi ci
metterò una vita perché è difficilissimo
ma devo sicuramente bacchettare qualcosa
no io comunque ciò questi oggetti quali
sono il cacciavite un martello che però
non mi sembrano una mazza in questo
momento proprio la ragazza cosa del
successo svitato la roba lì
aziz vitali ma
[Musica]
grazie non ho capito ma va bene next e
sono quelli più difficili questi ecco
infatti come non detto
cos'è sta roba anch'io
[Musica]
qualcuno che mi spiega persone mahjong
poi sia questo gioco ci giochiamo quando
ero piccolo ok non ho capito
va bene andiamo il primo l'ho fatto a
caso il secondo l'ho fatto ancora più a
caso però nel primo avevo ragionato ed è
incredibile che sia riuscito il secondo
completamente
che bello abbiamo degli elementi al
abbiamo una pera delle ciliegie una
banana
e poi c'è l'inverno l'inverno sta
arrivando a devo cliccare ok ho capito
il colore parka vacca sono scarso luna
marte perfetto questa raisi ogni tanto
si alternano livelli incasinatissima
livelli abbastanza easy anche per me che
sono uno youtuber l'ultima parola e
porte doors what's your name
qual è il tuo nome ciao mi chiamo fa dj
lo schiera fa vj fa festa la pizzera mi
dispiace lory lory è veramente era lori
sul serio ha dato faccio un simbolo devo
colorare in base alla roba linee non è
che io vi giuro sto facendo h a caso non
cup non capisco cosa sto clicca su tre
livelli a caso non ho capito niente
il bello è che la gente diventa pazza
verso gioco ci rimane bloccato su un
livello per anni e io a caso contestarla
questa catena f toni f
diamo la fff no 35 mettiamo numero del
piano vediamo se è giusto 35 è perfetto
questa questa non era a casa questa ci
ho provato va bene o questi sa livelli
difficile neanche quelli normali grazie
a tutti grazie mille sono
pagato apra mente l'ordine in base alla
freccia allora nell'oceano prima ci sono
i pesci
poi c'è il cane poi la mela sull'albero
poi l'aereo per la luna perfetto e fin
qua easy e poi non è detto magari il
cane sta sopra l'albero perchè c'è
finito in qualche modo ocean barile
[Musica]
ok
perfetto non ho neanche capito cosa ho
fatto ma va bene cento floors arrivano
al 50 entro oggi dai secondo me si scusa
e sto roba qua lo santo iddio amica di
andare a tempo siete pazzi perfetto un
fenomeno grandissimo vicari sto
prendendo troppo di me stesso
next solo quattro linee a devo
completare il coso con solo quattro
linee 1 2 1 2 3 4 3 1 2 3 non lo so ma
porca vacca 112
no 12
3 un macello come fai con solo quattro
linee come fai con cui aiuto sono scemo
no e questo non lo so rega giuro
mica tutti quanti che state guardando il
video che sapete esattamente la
soluzione io non lo so ma posso partire
anche di qua a una specie posso partire
anche dai bordi in altro discorso
2 3 e 4 perfetto non sapevo potessi
partire dai bordi e che ne so
[Musica]
poi non ho abbassato tutto il volume non
solo diminuito leggermente prove
ecco questo mi fa schifo schiacciamo lì
col martello e schifo
maledetti e non posso affidarmi sempre
al culo è impossibile che riesca ad
azzeccarle tutte cosa mi vogliono dire
le mostre
[Risate]
prossimo livello o questo sì che cari
però apriti a queste sono chiuse così si
apre fino qua questo è vedeva bè cosa
vedo
no basta o prima o poi nella mia vita
troverò uno scopo
ma non è questo giorno non mi va di
impegnare anche i compiti in classe
facciamo cosi poi qualcosa che usciva
giusto cosa avevo comunque non fatti già
13 e dall'inizio alla pallina di prima
eccola per passare giu
ne fa così eccola qua
let's go baby let's go le nex piano
dovrà farlo così l'ascensore di casa mia
secondo me è più in casinò trovare la
porta per chi mi consegna i parchi un g2
3b gulati iv v a ok il primo è g quindi
il primo proprio g grigio primo grigio
secondo white terzo black quarto white
chiaro molto bene quel che livello siamo
tipo 45 35 offerti al 50 poi basta al
palloncino la devo mettere sicuramente
in mezzo questa roba tosta a cos'era la
rotta e marcette qua ho tratto un
coltello tagliamo il palloncino esposta
lo scorso risposto lo sposto lo let's go
o baby mama mia oggi perlustratore di
piani preferito ok ok bene andiamo
avanti 47 da in cuore che ha lasciato
per unirli tutti lo portare
l'elettricità nel posto giusto
credo è poi non lo so dio mio spero così
così ma donne un fenomeno oggi un
fenomeno 48 quasi cinquanta ragazzi
machete a devo contare quanti fiori ci
sono chiamare questa una cagata 12345
bianchi non ha detto a 45 e gialli 1234
project ben 49 amici miei
l'ultimo per oggi ragazzi l'ultimo va
bene la tavola periodica enter password
parcheggio erogati dai io so di essere
bravo di kick ass
ho sempre fatto così miei compiti in
chimica se guardate sono passato l'anno
titolari che funziona
ok forse stavolta non funziona la mia
tattica infallibile 6 strano
vale è spiegarsi del 6 assi della
tattica infallibile magari devo
semplicemente dire il piano 50 fit chi
fa pass pass w.post password ma va a
cagare va lo sostiene passo è una cagata
incredibile cinquantesimo era anybody
ero ragazzino che questo video spero che
vi sia piaciuto mi piace che a
risollevare descrizione se non siete
consiglieri e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo vi da quanto difficile da
ragazzi
[Musica]
no